-Finally, we have
exactly 12 shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for that
beloved "Tonight Show"
tradition.
It's time for
"12 Days of Christmas Sweaters"!
-♪ "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters" ♪
♪ 12 days left ♪
-That's right.
Every show between
now and Christmas,
we will be giving
one lucky audience member
a spectacular Christmas sweater
from the Countdown
to Christmas Cabinet.
Since there are 12 shows left,
let's open door number 12.
[ Drumroll ]
Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Wow. This is gorgeous.
Look at this.
I don't know what that is.
Holy moly.
Alright, now let's see
who's going home with
tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number, okay?
If I call your number,
I need you to jump up
and let me know where you are.
Quest, can I get
a drumroll, please?
[ Drumroll ]
Who wants me
to pick their number?
It's a good sweater.
[ Cheers and applause ]
442!
♪♪
Hi!
How you doing?
-Good. How are you?
-I'm fantastic.
What is your name
and where are you from?
-Maria from Colombia.
-Maria from Colombia!
Oh, my goodness.
Maria, you have
a beautiful sweater on.
Does it get
a little chilly in Colombia?
-Um, no.
-No.
So this is perfect,
because those rare occasions
when it does become chilly,
you're going to have something.
Do you have anything like this?
-No.
-No. Would you like to
try it on?
-Of course.
-Oh, my God.
Guys, give it up for
Maria from Colombia.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You got your gla-- Oh.
-Thank you.
-No pr--
Oh, Maria, this is --
I mean, this is gor--
Look at this. That's gorgeous.
Oh, you're a model.
Thank you so much.
Give it up for Maria, everybody.
Thanks again.
Stick around. We'll be
right back with Olivia Rodrigo!